chantage menaces de mort et harcèlement
chelsea 2 gouttes se remémore la
violence verbale que lui a fait subir
son ex conjointe et l'a vécu cette
situation pendant quatre ans avant de le
quitter pour de bon en 2016 celle ci a
encore de la difficulté à en parler mais
pour la première fois elle a accepté de
raconter son histoire publiquement afin
de dénoncer une situation trop
fréquentes à l'aide bridge pour être
plus à l'aise pendant l'entrevue
la femme de 32 ans a imposé une
condition ne pas faire face à la caméra
la violence à la maison a été déclenchée
par le problème de consommation d'alcool
de son conjoint
puis elle est tombée enceinte et
raconte-t-elle et les choses ont empiré
si elle a eu le courage de dénoncer son
abuseur c'est grâce à cet homme bilquez
un inspecteur de la police de lethbridge
à la retraite
aujourd'hui l'homme passe presque tout
son temps à aider les victimes de
violences conjugales
non mais la crise des opioïdes et le
taux de pauvreté élevé à l'aide bridge
contribuer à ce phénomène les budget la
ville au canada où il ya le plus de
violences conjugales selon des données
de statistique canada en 2018 près de
600 cas comme celui de chelsea de good
ont été rapportés à la police tandis
qu'à montréal par exemple pour le même
bassin de population
il y en a eu la moitié moins selon des
intervenants dans la communauté il ya
donc urgence d'agir surtout que d'après
eux le problème ferait en réalité
beaucoup plus gras personnes soit 6 de
weeds les travailleuses du seul refuge
de lethbridge ne suffisent pas à la
tâche
elles doivent refuser ans
moyenne 1500 demandes par année par
manque de lits pour les victimes
chelsea n'est pas surprise de voir que
la réalité surpasse les statistiques de
la police
selon elle le système de justice n'est
pas adapté pour les victimes de
violences conjugales
à tel point que si elle avait su ce
qu'il attendait chelsea n'aurait pas été
porté plainte à la police
la police de l'aide bruit et dur
reconnaît ses torts et s'engage à faire
mieux en formant ses agents sur la
notion de traumatisme
même si chelsea de groot a abandonné
l'idée de voir son ex conjoint accusés
elle retournera quand même devant les
tribunaux prochainement pour tenter
d'obtenir la garde complète de sa fille
de 7 ans et cette fois elle espère
gagner ici charlotte du mollet radio
canada lethbridge